- [Instructor] Welcome to the
meditation on procrastination.
And somewhat ironically,
I've been procrastinating
making this meditation.
So we're all in the same boat together.
So as with all meditations,
posture and breathing
makes a big difference.
So I really encourage you
to find a nice, firm seat to sit on.
If your legs don't fall asleep,
you can sit on the ground as well.
But try to sit with your back
upright, really good posture.
Breathe in, breathe out,
a little bit slower, a
little bit deeper every time.
You can lay your hands on your lap.
I like to leave them face up.
And when you're ready,
you can soften your gaze,
and slowly close your eyes,
breathing in, breathing out.
Now procrastination is
an interesting thing.
I'm not sure whether we human beings
are the only animals we
know of that procrastinate.
It's maybe worth some
research for somebody
to figure that out.
But we clearly do it.
And a lot of meditation
is about becoming aware of our thoughts,
and observing our thoughts,
and realizing that we
are not our thoughts,
even though many times, our
thoughts seem to control us,
or even overwhelm us.
And so let's do that.
Let's try to observe those thoughts
that are making us put off something
that we know we need to do.
Why do you think you are
putting that thing off?
I'll tell you what happens to be usually
for my experience.
It usually is, I'm afraid to start,
because I might realize that
it's harder than I expected,
or I might not do as well as I expected,
or I might make a mistake.
Maybe I don't think I'm
prepared enough to start.
Another way to think about it is,
we're getting too caught up in the outcome
versus enjoying the journey,
or enjoying whatever the thing is
that you're putting off,
'cause that's just a part
of this fun experience.
And so I find that when I tell myself,
self, define yourself by
the action, not the outcome.
Don't define yourself by
whether you succeed or fail.
Define yourself as making
the effort, showing up,
and enjoying it, laughing at yourself,
laughing at this mystery
that we call life,
and just putting one foot
in front of the other,
and realizing it's not so bad.
And then you can put the other foot
in front of that one, and keep going.
And slowly but surely,
you realize that you're
making a lot of progress.
And the more you make that progress,
the more that you actually enjoy it,
especially if you're not
doing it at the last minute.
And now, I'll give you about a minute
for you to repeat something in your mind
that can hopefully short-circuit
any of those thoughts
that have been keeping
you from taking action.
For the next minute or
so, repeat to yourself,
that you really enjoy taking action.
You're lucky that you're in a position
to be able to take action.
The outcome?
It is what it is.
You enjoy action.
You're lucky to be able to take action.
The outcome is what it is.
Keep thinking that for
the next minute or so,
and I'll be back, don't worry.
All right.
So when you're ready,
really at your own time,
just become a little bit more
aware of your surroundings,
a little bit more aware of your body,
a little bit more aware of your breaths,
and slowly open your eyes.
And so I'll finish with one last tip:
Sometimes we put something off
because it just feels
big, or overwhelming.
What I like to do then is say hey,
let me just put 20 minutes towards it,
and see where I am at
the end of 20 minutes.
If I didn't make any
progress, no big deal.
It was juts 20 minutes.
But if I did make some progress, great.
I did the 20 minutes, I deserve a break.
If after a five or 10-minute break
I'm ready to put in another
20 minutes, awesome.
If at the end of the 20
minutes, I wanna keep going,
I shouldn't stop myself.
I should keep going.
(laughs)
But when you view things as hey,
I'm just committing 20
minutes to something,
it doesn't feel as intimidating.
You just own it.
You say hey, I can do
anything for 20 minutes.
And I can enjoy anything for 20 minutes.
And then you'll wanna do it.
Put a smile on your face
and own that action.
And not only will you make progress,
but you're gonna have a good time.
And so take it wit that playful mindset.
Enjoy it.
Smile.
And just get started.
And I think you'll find
you'll be procrastinating a lot, lot less.